[Musique]
l'amélioration des temps la volonté de
gagner ou plutôt de ne pas perdre non
seulement dans le cyclisme et dans
presque toutes les disciplines sportives
a entraîné une surenchère inadmissible
la preuve la voici le chemin de croix du
malheureux simpson je pense que c'est là
dans ce virage à la sortie de ce virage
que le 13 juillet 1967
tom simpson trouvait la mort sur les
pentes du ventoux oui c'est ici même
dans une atmosphère étouffante à deux
kilomètres du sommet un homme izac sur
la route
ce coureur c'est l'anglais tom simpson
les envoyés spéciaux de panoramas
maurice mvno jean louis normand sont là
pour vous présenter ce document
exceptionnel
[Musique]
respiration artificielle masque à
oxygène les techniques de réanimation
sont impuissants simpson est toujours
dans un état comateux état qui nécessite
une rapide évaluation sur le centre
hospitalier d'avignon à 17h40 les
médecins constater le décès de tom
simpson et refusé le permis d'inhumer
voilà et nous en revenons maintenant au
tour de france qui je vous le disais en
début de ce journal a été gagnée comme
prévu par laurent fignon
alors que l'étape du jour la dernière a
été remportée par le suisse gilbert glos
on a eu un peu peur cet après-midi sur
les pavés des champs elysées qu'elle
était mouillée ce qui a donné plusieurs
chutes spectaculaires mais la hiérarchie
établie après l'étape contre la montre
de dijon n'a en rien été bousculé et la
foule énorme qui a suivi à paris
l'arrivée du tour n'a pas été déçu celui
qu'elle attendait était au rendez-vous
et celui là c'était bien
laurent laurent fignon
il
c'est un beau tour de france très beau
et chaud ça vous a rappellé souvenir oui
mon premier tour de france par une icône
a tellement bien marché papillon
qui sait finir
comment ces grands champions il mesure
combien je sais pas vous avez qui a
gagné tour bat sinon c'est hinault qui a
gagné toulon il va gagner le pot il va
gagner tourbe
est-ce qu'il a eu du mal à gagner le
tour oh non pas tellement
est ce que vous connaissez le rang
fignon
bon c'est à dire et c'est à dire bon
j'ai cette allure ce même pas ce que
c'est qu'un vélo
[Musique]
c'est un bon gars et dernière étape du
tour de france
alors monsieur vous avez suivi pour le
france a eu je suis de l'avant dit vous
avez suivi le tour de france le
rouennais dit toi à voir qu'ici vous
pensez du tour de france 80 de ses
chiens vous trouvez que ça a été un joli
tournafond joué qu est ce qu a gagné ses
prisons comment ils jouent les gens
n'ont pas fillon fignon chignon ça
s'écrit f
ign au n fignon c'est le nouveau
champion d'un nouveau tour le dernier
mais de loin le plus rétro et le plus
passionnant de ces dix dernières années
et quand un maillot jaune arrive sur les
champs-elysées que craint-il sinon une
chute et pour ce maillot jaune l'anxiété
est encore plus grande lorsque une
averse tombe sur les pavés poussiéreux
et quand l'averse tombe les coureurs
aussi c'est presque fatal et yahoo
hotmail en sait quelque chose
au fait où et fignon on a vu wind and
mais le voilà fignon et c'est bon signe
on l'a cherché avec inquiétude ce
coureur dont les cheveux sont de la même
couleur que le maillot le voilà
rassurant non
et puis c'est le dernier tour et puis
c'est formidable formidable parce que
pascal jules démarre jules qu'on appelle
déjà julo imaginer une victoire de julo
le copain de fignon sur les champs
elysées pour une apothéose se serait tu
n'as poté mais j ai rejoint et arrive le
dernier passage sur la place de la
concorde hinault à gagner sur les champs
elysées l'an passé laurent fignon pense
qu'il n'y a aucune raison pour ne pas
faire de même
il démarre
[Applaudissements]
il démarre mais kelly a pris sa roue
suivi par le suisse glace
et puis comme d'habitude c'est le sprint
sur les champs-elysées
et kelly qui tente de remonter de la
hausse mais klaus qui passe d'un boyau
glaus bas donc kelly mais fini on passe
à 22 ans il est avec felice gimondi le
plus jeune vainqueur du tour de france
de l'après guerre
il portait le dossard numéro 15 c'est
celui de la voiture de prost fignon
prost ne vous dit rien
[Musique]
2e tour de france cycliste celui là avec
une étape beaucoup plus calme que celle
de la veille à fleurance et l'ancien
champion de france réagisse claire qui
l'a emporté au sprint le français pascal
simon conserve le maillot journée
pourtant il est tombé dans des
conditions que certains ont jugées
douteuses
suffisamment en tout cas pour relancer
la polémique sur la loi du milieu dans
le peloton il a ce soir une omoplate
fracturée
d'autant qu'un peu plus tard on
apprenait que job douteux mais lequel
jean françois rodriguez s'était dopé
lors des premières étapes du tour
outre une amende il risque un
déclassement à la dernière place des
étapes incriminés et 10 minutes de
pénalisation au classement général alain
vernon un drame a marqué l'étape
d'aujourd'hui donc ont annoncé comme une
étape de transition après la douloureuse
traversée des pyrénées c'est christian
jourdan qui se relève ici mais la chute
du kilomètre 46 a surtout fait une
victime de marque puisque pascal simon a
bien failli monter dans l'ambulance
pourtant la loi du tour dicte toujours
ces conditions et tandis que simon
reporter endolori
régis clair le champion de france 82
remporté au sprint la 11e étape à
florence devant jourdan bien revenu et
le lente et freaks pirard le vainqueur
de créteil
[Applaudissements]
c'est phil anderson qui règle le sprint
du peloton avec deux minutes et 3
secondes de retard tandis que hotmail
qu'on l'apprend convaincu de dopage
rétrograde à la 25e place avec plus de
16 minutes de retard quant à simon il ne
décolère pas
alors qu'un homme blessé je pense que
c'est normal après sa première un
accident ou un avantage vous entendu
critiquer violemment un des adversaires
un peu d'eau oui parce que quand dans la
beauce et rezé il a climat d'ici à
quelques a fait tomber maintenant cette
enquête fait pas je veux pratiquer un
coureur dans une chute sylvain n'est pas
responsable mais s'il en est responsable
doit être plus non c'est pas la crise en
cours que c'était intentionnel dans le
dos parce que lui surtout à se bousculer
en attendant ce moment là on pourra se
plaindre quand le ton et je te croise
les jambes allaient se soient envoyés
pour moi c'est vraiment facile à faire
ses bourreaux qui est tombé parce qu'il
a touché la roue a gardé pays majesté
dans les environs c'est quand je savais
même pas que simon est tombé quand on
achète ses produits mais c'est la guerre
on peut tout dire annoncé par
qu'agostino partis eux ils ont commencé
à arroser moi je me suis mis avec qui
roulait et puis bourreau a touché la
roue a à son équipier puis pourrait
tomber et piment est tombé dans sa roue
vous plaidez vous coupable du tout on va
lutter pascal simon souffre ce soir
d'une fracture de l'omoplate dos il
devra conserver son bras immobilisé
durant près d'un mois
j'ai peur car je sentais vraiment dans
mon épaule et vers la remontée de mon
vélo je suis trouvée loi mais chez des
souris le procédé j'ai porté les faisans
à la fin du tour de france j'avais mieux
de l'état et je dois dire un grand merci
à toute l'équipe de jour qui font de
manière
à m'avoir amené à florence et maintenant
à moins d'avoir beaucoup de courage pour
essayer finir ce tour de france
le reportage de patrick naf est prêt un
reportage sur la chute spectaculaire de
bernard hinault et sur l'état du
cycliste patrick bernard hinault blessés
à l'arrivée de la 14e étape
autrans saint-etienne diagnostic double
fracture des os propres du nez et
entaille au cuir chevelu
tous ces produits dans les 300 derniers
mètres lors du sprint du peloton
inovallée anderson wind n est âgé dorel
s'accroche c'est la chute
le sud dont la cause reste mystérieuse
l'autre victime de cette 14e étape c'est
le vainqueur le colombien luis herrera
qui tombe dans une descente à quelques
kilomètres de l'arrivée blé à la
pommette et au fond mais rien de grave
parti seul au 117e km le colombien a
franchi la ligne d'arrivée avec 47
secondes d'avancé sur ses adversaires
c'est sa deuxième victoire d'étape
derrière que l'esprit pour la seconde
place d'un sprint remporté par le belge
ludo peters devant le lieutenant de
bernard hinault l'américain greg lemond
et ebp et robert forest
[Applaudissements]
le gros du peloton arrivera deux minutes
plus tard et comme le veut le règlement
des coureurs qui ont chuté dans le
dernier kilomètre sont crédités du même
temps pour ino d'hondt crossfire mais
pas trop de mal
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde il n'y a rien sous son nez
cassé de police il y deux points de la
tête
et mme reste maître du genre mais devra
alors je pense que c'est le plus
important s'est passé dans le sprint
il emmenait le sprint je crois que c'est
madiot qui a dû apprécier d'aller et moi
je me suis jetée pour aller dans les
sprints avec la victime et il ya un
coureur qui arrivait sur le côté km est
ce que c'est le foot d'anderson j'ai pas
vu le film je crois qu'il faut voir le
film pour savoir si c'est de sa faute si
c'est pas de sa faute
alors que comme ça je veux sur le côté
de la tête
aussi rien face à la furia deux poêles
marque de fabrique ici le nez cassé et
autrement le reste il n'y a rien du tout
lié au classement général hinault
conserve le maillot jaune et greg lemond
valises une bonne opération en reprenant
plus d'une minute à stephen roche et
sean kelly 5e steve bauer on passe au
cyclisme tour de france est 12ème étape
aujourd'hui 12 juillet c'est normal
entreprises la gaillarde et bordeaux
victoire d'un américain au sprint
abbas zaki gagnant gagnant très français
gerard le maillot jaune martial gayant
malade est ce qu'on retiendra surtout
que cette étape 110 bien c'est la chute
et l'abandon de sean kelly qui était
l'un des favoris
pierre fa donnerait 50e kilomètre le
peloton et près de sarlat un
attroupement du mouvement un homme le dr
portes seront sur le lieu du drame
vous l'avez reconnu sean kelly en est la
victime courageux irlandais remonte sur
son vélo
aidé par ses coéquipiers et au prix d'un
fantastique et fort le favori du tour
repart
par pour longtemps malheureusement va km
20 km d'horreur c'en est trop la douleur
lampant kelly le maudit s'arrête
diagnostic fracture de la clavicule
après le tour d'espagne et paris roubaix
le tour de france
c'en est fini pour kelly l'histoire de
cette 12e étape retiendrons donc
l'abandon de kelly la victoire au sprint
de david phinney et le maintien du
maillot jaune sur les épaules du
français martial gayant
au menu de demain les premiers cols de
montagne
madame monsieur bonsoir le tour de
france commence mal l'arrivée à
armentières cet après midi c'est le
sprint final les coureurs se déporte sur
la droite de la route vers les barrières
de sécurité et c'est la chute
plusieurs coureurs percuté un policier
qui prenait une photo de coureurs ont
été sérieusement blessé le belge denis
seine et le français jalabert qui était
le meilleur français de ce tour le récit
complet des événements
thierry clopeau voici le vélo de laurent
jalabert ou tout du moins ce qu'il en
reste après le choc
à près de 70 km heure dix secondes plus
tôt c'est le sprint
un policier imprudente et y aller par
rapport à la barrière qui prend une
photo le landais nelly scène le frappe
alors de plein fouet
derrière si jalabert qui heurte lui
aussi pleine phase l'agent des forces de
l'ordre est un panneau publicitaire
stupéfaction dans le public
les deux coureurs une policier assez
sérieusement blessé sont immédiatement
secouru par les médecins du tout premier
diagnostic
le policier souffre d'un enfoncement du
thorax laurent jalabert ensemble à
plusieurs lésions à la mâchoire et des
fractures aux incisives quentin et
lycéennes traumatisme crânien il est
transporté comme les deux autres à
l'hôpital d'armentières
puis sur le chu de lille pour examen au
scanner mais d'ores et déjà les deux
coureurs sont déclarés inaptes à
poursuivre le tour
la question que tout le monde se pose ce
soir est ce une faute d'organisation ou
une erreur humaine 50 mètres de
l'arrivée un policier qui a au milieu de
la route peuple à la photo de desprès
massive de colère
la photographie sur la ligne d'arrivée
pour la direction du tour il y a bien eu
faute du policier tentative
d'explication c'est donc une espèce de
d'erreur humaine de la part de sept
jaunes police on peut ne pas incriminer
totalement dans la mesure où ces agents
de police locaux que nous rendrons
chaque jour sont différents qu'ils ne
connaissent pas les usagers tour de
france les risques du tour de france
mais enfin n'oubliez pas que le peloton
traverse villes les villages à parfois
plus de 60 kilomètres heure les voitures
du tour à 100 km heure alors surtout
rester derrière les barrières c'est
votre sécurité et la sécurité des
coureurs qui ont dépens il faut que ce
tour parce qu'une fête
cyclistes à celui que l'on arrête plus
laurent jalabert vainqueur cet
après-midi du critérium international
après ses victoires dans paris-nice et
milan san remo laurent jalabert qui
savoure d'autant plus ses succès qu'il
revient de loin après son accident du
tour de france l'année dernière thierry
clopeau laurent jalabert a dû se croire
maudit à l'arrivée de la deuxième étape
ce matin
le coureur dnc a failli revivre une bien
mauvaise aventure une petite collision
avec un spectateur
heureusement sans gravité malgré cet
incident de parcours cela ne l'a pas
empêché de remporter cet après-midi le
critérium international
jalabert enjoindre c'est toute la france
du vélo qui se met à rêver une image
entretenir jusqu'au mois de juillet
jusqu'au tour de france une fois le
classique d'avril terminer mon principal
objectif sera le tour de france est
alors à ce moment là tout ce que je vais
faire ce soir en fonction du tour donc à
ce moment là je commence à y penser
pourtant laurent jalabert revient de
loin le 3 juillet dernier à armentières
il percute un policier dans le sprint
final
la chute est terrible violence et les
dégâts pour jalabert sont considérables
cage thoracique enfoncée
plusieurs fractures de la mâchoire et
des bleus un peu partout sur son lit
d'hôpital jalabert souffre mais ne doute
pas que martine aubry et laurent
jalabert à force de courage à ceux tenus
les moyens de cette ambition
il ya trois semaines c'était paris nice
la première grande course par étapes de
la saison
la première victoire du revenant plus
fort encore une semaine plus tard il
remporte sa première grande classique
milan san remo devant l'italien
fondriest jalabert rejoint alors les
plus grands
sa victoire aujourd'hui au critérium
international de la route est carrément
un exploit historique jamais un coureur
n'avait remporté ses trois courses
d'affilée
bien sûr on commence à penser très fort
au tour de france le tour qui lui a valu
tant de souffrance mais qui n'a pas fait
lui porter malheur en 92 avec une
victoire d'étape en prime jalabert avait
endossé ce sont les champs-elysées le
maillot vert du classement par points
avec de nouvelles qualités de grimpeur
qu'on ne soupçonnait pas il peut
désormais rêver d'un maillot d'une autre
couleur le jaune il a si bien mais le
tour de france a débuté dans le drame
hier soir avec la chute de chris
boardman le britannique champion du
monde du contre la montre
chris boardman a tout tenté dans le
prologue à saint brieuc sous la pluie à
la nuit tombée mais il a chuté au bout
d'une minute trente de course
il souffre d'une double fracture à la
cheville gauche et au bras droit thierry
clopeau et alain poirier l'ont
rencontrée sur son lit d'hôpital avant
qu'il ne reparte pour manchester
je prends des risques trop pour la
descente
c'est connu je suis 50 du cirque on a
derrière de franchissement donc se fonde
cette fois ci pour gagner des prologues
je ne suivais pas de prologue au jeu
trop ambitieux pour les dix ans je n'ai
pas tout le plus mauvais virage après
600 m c'est fini je suis troy de sujets
c'est parce que je m'en prenais un peu
tuméfié pour fait la grande course de
trois semaines avec la première
opportunité pour avancer mon corps est
un super motivé bon j'ai déçu mais ce
concert à la future le docteur m'a dit
si ce même de moi je sais qu'à celles à
dieu après moi je pense titre x c'est
possible pour la charge et demande donc
j'essaye pour le championnat souvient il
a la balle à niort il avait reçu de
l'hapoel
j'espère c'est là même la merci qui
cette étape la plus attendue a donc
commencé dans le drap je lisais avec ce
matin la chute mortelle de fabio
casartelli 25 ans champion olympique à
barcelone récit laurent frédéric bollée
immobile est pratiquement déjà sans vie
fabio casartelli j'ai même le sol dans
une mare de sang
à ses côtés d'autres coureurs impliqués
dans une chute terrible on est au 34e km
de la 15e étape du tour de france
au détour d'un virage de la descente du
portet d'aspet le drame a frappé
manifestement l'italien alors thing des
bornes en béton qui longe la route le
choc le plonge alors immédiatement dans
un coma profond
difficile de savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé eca crevaison fautes en
tout cas sans casque sous la chaleur
aujourd'hui casartelli ne se relèvera
pas il avait fêté son 25e anniversaire
il y a deux jours les secours pourtant
sont arrivés très vite
soigné sur place puis évacuée par
hélicoptère casartelli sera victime de
trois arrêts cardiaques pendant son
transfert le décès sera prononcée
officiellement à 14 heures également
touchés dans l'accident l'allemand
baldinger et l'italien périgny souffrent
de traumatismes divers
quant aux français de rester il a plongé
dans le ravin et s'est blessé gravement
à la cuisse gauche
professionnelle depuis deux ans
casartelli le premier coureur à décéder
sur le tour depuis tony simpson en 67
on se souviendra de lui comme le
champion olympique en titre de la
spécialité en 92 à barcelone il avait
triomphé et avait offert à tous les
observateurs un visage rayonnant à
l'image de sa jeunesse pleine d'avenir
au tour de france et le suisse alex
houleux qui portait le maillot jaune ce
matin au départ de la première étape le
suisse en effet remporté hier le
prologue battant de deux petites
secondes le britannique chris boardman
qui l'an dernier avait été victime d'une
grave chute lors précisément du prologue
à saint brieuc noyés alors sous l'orage
cleeren juillet 1993 dans le tgv qui
l'emmène à paris pour la dernière étape
du tour légal indurain découvre dans la
presse l'exploit de chris boardman qui
vient de battre le record de l'heure un
exploit qui n'a pas échappé à l'équipe
gan qui s'adjuge des services de
l'anglais le 2 juillet 94
chris boardman prend donc le départ de
son premier tour de france et quel débat
il remporte le prologue en établissant
un record de vitesse encore inégalé à ce
jour mais il abandonne le peloton au
bout de deux semaines le 1er juillet 95
boardman repart en trombe sous leur âge
de saint brieuc mais son prologue à lui
ne durera que 3 km un mauvais virage une
terrible chute de fracture dormann
rentrer à la maison
en vacances dans la terre est ma famille
serait la première fois donne
trois ans je reste à la maison on était
sept si c'est bon parce que j'ai le
temps pour qu'on te plaît aux pour
penser pour le futur ça c'est un bon
l'expérience
hier goldman n'était pourtant pas très
rassuré lorsqu'il a pris le départ
difficile en effet de chasser les
mauvais souvenirs lorsqu'on doit à
nouveau à prouver une route mouillée des
virages serrés mais cette année il a
décidé de terminer le tour alors il a
opté pour la prudence
ce qui n'a pas empêché de se classer
deuxième de ce prologue ya deux petites
secondes du suisse alex d'où le même
lorsqu'il ne prend pas de risque chris
boardman reste vraiment un super membres
du chrono
[Applaudissements]
le russe berline s'empare du maillot
jaune à l'issue d'une première étape de
montagne épique entre chambéry et les
arcs luc leblanc est le héros du jour il
sera en direct avec tous dans ce journal
les vacances débutent sous la pluie et
le froid inquiétude à la sncf après
l'incarcération de loïk le floch prigent
et les témoignages accablants pour
mladic et karadzic au tribunal
international de la haye madame monsieur
bonsoir le tour de france a connu l'une
de ces étapes les plus folles entre
chambéry et les arcs un cocktail
détonnant de pluie de vente de nuages et
de cols à franchir
au fil des kilomètres on a assisté au
décrochage jalabert à l'abandon du
maillot jaune à des chutes
spectaculaires et à la défaillance d'une
du rennes ce soir le russe berline et
maillot jaune après cette étape
remportée de quelle façon par luc
leblanc récit d'une journée un peu folle
clair et nous on l'imaginé en jaune mais
il a vécu une journée noire laurent
jalabert lâché dès les premiers
kilomètres de cette première étape de
montagne dans l'ascension du col de la
madeleine
laurent jalabert qui malgré l'aide de
ses coéquipiers ne parviendra jamais à
rejoindre le peloton et dans ce peloton
bien sûr il y a une durée d'où le holà
nobert dinero munger bref tous les
favoris qui maintiennent une cadence
d'enfer
il y a bien sûr aussi des tentatives
d'échappées comme celle des cartes in
viérin qu'est le blanc dans la montée du
cormet de roseland mais les deux
français n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
un jour comme celui là la solidarité
nationale ne joue pas la bagarre
heureusement sera de courte durée car il
faut rester concentré la route est
dangereuse et dans la descente vers
bourg-saint-maurice
johan bruyneel bascule dans le ravin une
chute heureusement sans gravité dans la
montée vers les arcs luc leblanc
effectué une extraordinaire roman p
l'ancien champion du monde s'impose avec
plus de 50 secondes d'avancé sur le
peloton
un peloton qui a distancé miguel
indurain le quintuple vainqueur du tour
de france est à son tour victime d'une
incroyable défaillance il coupera la
ligne avec plus de quatre minutes de
retard rétrogradant à la 14e place du
classement général
quant à laurent jalabert arrivée 13
minutes après luc leblanc il sait qu'il
a perdu toute chance de remporter le
tour de france
un bond de sport avec le tour de france
le maillot jaune change d'épaulés
revient à l'estonien car ces [ __ ] c'est
le belge tom steels qui remporte cette
deuxième étape une étape plutôt
mouvementée nathanaël de rincquesen
l'hydroglisseur voilà bien le meilleur
moyen pour voir le peloton progressé
tout au long des quatre km du gua de
noirmoutier
le bois devait marquer les esprits il va
laisser des traces
une chute collective au milieu du
peloton entraîne un embouteillage
la chaussée est étroite 104 coureurs
sont pris au piège pas mieux quelques
favoris joue le prix n'est roggo type
rochard ils arriveront à saint nazaire
avec plus de 6 minutes de retard sur ce
groupe de soixante dix échappés bien
malgré eux sur la ligne d'arrivée tom
steels s'impose juste devant yann type
qui situe les habiles aujourd'hui
notamment lors des sprints bonifications
a repris 30 secondes à lance armstrong
bien plus qu'il n'en fallait pour
dépasser l'américain au classement
général et au pire à l'estonie le
premier maillot jaune de son histoire
laurent jalabert est en direct avec nous
de lescar dans les pyrénées atlantiques
et laurent jalabert quelle étape 162 km
en solitaire s'y colle dans la journée
tout seul ce soir le maillot à pois du
meilleur grimpeur pour la première fois
de votre carrière et vous allez nous
faire croire vous n'êtes pas un
spécialiste de la montagne
oui si j'en étais un jour attendue
finale et jaur essayer de gagner au
sommet aujourd'hui mais bon c'est vrai
que je sais pas non plus minables en
montagne mais bon j'ai besoin si je
gagnais 2 d'attaquer de loin comme ça
c'était bien tenté j'ai pris des gros
risques mais mais c'était ce prix là que
j'avais une chance de gagner aujourd'hui
alors gros risques on va revoir l'image
vous avez été victime d'une chute c'est
quoi une justement une trop grande prise
de risques dans la descente où
finalement une grande fatigue
maintenant là précisément la descente
était terminée
c'était surtout la fatigue de régis
témoin lucide dans la dernière descente
j'ai fait une petite erreur de freinage
était juste trop bloquer les frères
l'avant je suis parti les renvois
victoire d'étape pour lance armstrong
qui vous rattrape in extremis caisse
conso qu'est ce qu'on ressent à ce
moment là après 162 kilomètres seul
c'est quoi c'est un grand courant d'air
qui passe c'était un courant d'air est
passé vite
bon même s'il m'a fait signe à la tête à
dix huit mois dont je peux parler ni
moins fallu autre chose qu'un vélo pour
montrer avec lui mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est le destin
c'est vrai c'était difficile d'aller au
bout mais j'ai quand même fait une belle
journée sur une belle étape
je suis très très content de ma journée
alors public considérable dans les
pyrénées aujourd'hui on vous a vu à
certains moments manifester votre
énervement à l'égard de certains kibaki
vous à rose qui vous pousse qui vous
tape même si c'est sympathique ça ça
énerve parfois non mais en règle
générale je suis resté très calme
aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu de problème avec
le public
bien au contraire si ce n'est peut-être
qu'une fois ou deux où on arrose avec de
l'eau trop froide et ça surprend un
petit peu mais mais bon rien rien me
bernard oui c'est vrai que c'est une
popularité énorme pour vous on a vu
beaucoup de panneaux et d' affiches à
votre nom alors deux victoires d'étapes
dont celle du 14 juillet ce maillot du
meilleur grimpeur pour la première fois
on vous souhaite de conserver encore
demain soir quoi qu'il arrive ce tour
restera un grand cru pour vous oui tout
à fait scissionner le meilleur c'est
notre meilleur et bon quoi qu'il arrive
et jusqu'à paris maintenant c'est clair
mais bon je vais essayer encore de faire
quelque chose au bien d'ici à la fin on
vous le souhaite merci beaucoup laurent
jalabert vous étiez en direct avec nous
aujourd'hui dans la plus éprouvante des
étapes pyrénéennes
lance armstrong s'est offert une très
sérieuse option sur une troisième
victoire consécutive dans le tour de
france l'américain désormais en jaune
l'a emporté au pla d'adet avec une
facilité toujours aussi déconcertante
une étape marquée par de nombreuses
chutes mais surtout une formidable
échappée en solitaire de laurent
jalabert 194km d'anthologie résumé par
nathanaël de rincquesen et alain poirier
sur la ligne de saint lary laurent
jalabert était bien le coureur le plus
attendu emporté dans la foule
le français a encore vécu une sacrée
journée 170 km d'échappée
seul face au peloton dans une étape aux
allures de montagnes russes
alors jalabert joue les équilibristes
dans les vertigineuse descente
pyrénéenne
après 80 km heure pas le temps de
reprendre son souffle
voilà déjà la route qui s'élève une
nouvelle difficulté sur le terrain des
grimpeurs jalabert n'est pas là pour
faire de la figuration
il enchaîne l'école et les attentions
plus du
les unes que les autres à 50 kilomètres
de l'arrivée le français à dix minutes
d'avancé sur armstrong
derrière jalabert la bagarre éclate
jan ullrich tente le tout pour le tout
mais n'arrive pas à décrocher armstrong
l'allemand prend des risques un peu trop
dans la descente de peyresourde
il rate un virage
plus de peur que de mal oulrich remonte
en selle prêt à se lancer aux trousses
de l'américain inutile armstrong
l'attend quelques kilomètres plus bas
d'ignorer ou attaquer quand champions
toujours en tête de la course jalabert
est à son tour victime d'une chute au
pied de la dernière ascension mais le
français repart quelques mètres plus
tard sous vélo lui joue des tours
encore des secondes de perdues à 10 km
de l'arrivée
comme pour lui ôter pour grey armstrong
dans les derniers lacets de la montée
vers saint lary démarre comme d'habitude
au nez et à la barbe d'une riche
jalabert est vite rejoint cette fois il
n'y a plus personne
sur le chemin de l'américain qui s'en va
remporter sa troisième victoire du tour
et enfilé son premier maillot jaune de
l'année certainement pas le dernier
l'étape s'annonçait décisive elle n'a
été réservé en même l'un de ses coups de
théâtre qui participent à la légende du
tour dix kilomètres avant l'arrivée jan
ullrich très bien parti est tombé dans
un virage alors qu'il disposait d'une
avance de deux secondes sur son
principal concurrent
lance armstrong l'américain a désormais
sa cinquième victoire à portée de roues
il a terminé l'épreuve troisième il
dispose désormais d'une avance d'une
minute 16 au classement général
l'épreuve contre la montre a été gagné
par l'écossais david millar qui avait
connu bien des déboires lors du prologue
compte rendu nathanaël de rincquesen la
dig picard un tour de france
ça tient parfois pas grand chose un
virage mal négocié et voilà les rêves de
victoire de jan ullrich qui s'envole
juste derrière même sam trombe lancé à
pleine vitesse ne laisse pas passer
l'occasion de reprendre quelques
précieuses secondes à son rival hulu je
repars sans conviction il a perdu le
tour
quand j'écoute chute je vais être
inquiet train qu'il est important pour
le tape vraiment un maillot jaune averti
en vaut deux armstrong gère son avance
et ne prend plus aucun risque
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
oulrich roule en éclaireur à plus de 54
km heure de moyenne
les deux hommes arrivent à nantes fut
des trombes d'eau oulrich à sa tête des
mauvais jours
il est 4e de l'étape est plus que jamais
deuxième du tour
[Applaudissements]
elle a dit ne pas toucher aux au pouce
pour la l'est et dix et de masse qui n'a
pas gagné d'étape à ce que
il y croyait vraiment
cet après midi sur la ligne d'arrivée
malgré la pluie et la fatigue
lance armstrong s'est laissé aller à
quelques signes extérieurs de bonheur
cette victoire
l'américain est tout de suite allé la
partager avec sa part demain soir lance
amstrong rejoindra anquetil merckx
hinault indurain dans la légende du tour
de france la première étape du tour de
france après la cérémonie de départ à
l'endroit même où des premières équipes
s'étaient élancés les à 100 en place à
la compétition la vraie avec une série
de chutes et la victoire de l'italien
alessandro pettachi natale d'haguenau
la chute est spectaculaire elle aurait
pu être dramatique
cet après midi à 500 mètres de la ligne
d'arrivée à mot le peloton connaît sa
première chute collective du tout une
quinzaine de coureurs tombe par terre
créons un étonnant embouteillages les
premiers blessés comme ici jimmy casper
sont immédiatement prise en charge les
mois touché passe la ligne un peu comme
ils peuvent
une certitude le tour commence mal
voilà chute inévitable mais bon là on a
évité toute la journée comme en 1903 le
tour s'offre un départ au réveil matin
de montgeron compéti et cotillons
accompagnent les coureurs
le public est comblé c'est exceptionnel
c'est pour ça que je suis venu la
déplacer que j'ai pas devant la télé
la thaïlande les collèges pour le plus
grand plaisir des spectateurs
la première échappée du centenaire et
française beneteau mangin et puis
quinger pause compagnie au peloton
ils comptent jusqu'à huit minutes
d'avancé malheureusement pour eux les
espoirs de victoire s'envole un peu
avant l'arrivée lorsque les équipes de
sprinteurs accélère
il réussit à vous de faire mémoire un
peloton lancé à 30 à l'heure on était un
dernier kilomètre est pas trop d'espoir
sur la ligne de mots l'italien
alessandro petacchi règle au sprint ce
qu'il reste du peloton
c'est sa première victoire sur le tour
de france bradley mcgee lui a toujours
le sourire
son aventure en jaune continue la france
avec un maillot jaune qui changent
encore des pôles schumacher victime
d'une chute et détrôner ce soir par le
luxembourgeois kirschen et c'est un
jeune espoir italien
ricco qui remporte l'étape sur place
note anaëlle de rincquesen régis mater
depuis début du tour c'est presque
devenu une tradition chaque jour dès les
premiers kilomètres de l'étape des
coureurs français faussé compagnie au
peloton
cima chabanel benoît vaugrenard et
freddy bichot multiplie les efforts
pendant 180 km sur les routes du massif
central
les trois hommes doivent se battre
contre la route qui s'élève le soleil
qui tape le peloton qui revient et
l'appui qui glace ça fait beaucoup pour
des échappées
aujourd'hui ce qui a permis de refroidir
un peu ça reste toujours des journées
s'il parce qu'il n'y a pas trop de bois
trop de plats toujours en prise
tout le monde connaît le massif central
c'est toujours difficile dans le peloton
la tension est palpable
cadel evans s'énerve contre un gendarme
qui a failli faire tomber
chavanel lui arrête les frais à 15
kilomètres de l'arrivée il a récupéré le
maillot de meilleur grimpeur
l'échappée est terminée débute alors une
nouvelle course riche en intensité en
rebondissements à 300 mètres de la ligne
stefan schumacher le maillot jaune
heurte la route d'un concurrent
il perd l'équilibré 32 secondes et sa
précieuse tunique pour cette première
arrivée au sommet valverde et evans sont
roue dans roue mais c'est ricardo ricco
l'italien qui s'imposent
les transalpins voient en lui le futur
pantani et en italie c'est un compliment
sur le podium
kim kirchen a sorti son plus beau
sourire depuis charlie gaulle il ya 50
ans
aucun luxembourgeois n'avait porté le
maillot jaune un dimanche de sport
maintenant avec d'abord la première
étape du tour en ligne après le prologue
hier les coureurs ont pris la direction
de bruxelles une étape de plat de
nombreuses chutes et un sprint remporté
par l'italien petacchi 36 ans et toutes
ses jambes apparemment junior le
benedetto et david hamel à mèze petit
village belge en effervescence pour le
passage de la grande boucle
c'est ici qu'habitent le cannibale eddy
merckx quintuple vainqueur du tour
possède une usine de cycles juste à côté
mèze c'est une terre de vélo
[Musique]
ici wallons et flamands sont d'accord
sur un point
merckx est un héros le plus fort le plus
grand maintenant le gardien en cov tout
le cas à mèze on n'a pas perdu une
miette de la rocambolesque première
étape marquée par une succession de
chutes c'est d'abord un chien qui
flanquent à terre une partie du peloton
dans le dernier kilomètre le maillot
jaune fabian cancellara chute à son tour
après un autre accrochage l'italien
petacchi 36 ans remporte l'étape à
bruxelles distancé cancellara conserve
le maillot jaune grâce au règlement
quand un coureur chute dans le dernier
kilomètre il est classé dans le même
temps que le vainqueur
c'est vraiment nerveux et à la fin
c'était la folie cancellara reste donc
le patron du sourd mais sur le podium
eddy merckx
lui a un peu volé la vedette le tour de
france maintenant avec une journée un
peu folle sur les pavés du nord
armstrong qui perd du temps chavanel qui
perd son maillot jaune et cancellara qui
redevient le patron a longtemps dit
mathieu ivanovski épique dantesque dans
la poussière des pavés du nord les
coureurs du tour ou là un train d'enfer
[Applaudissements]
treize kilomètres de souffrance du
peuple
ils ont vraiment ils vont vraiment au
bout jusqu'à ce qu'ils font chapeau bas
respect je le ferai pas cet après midi
le grand ménage a bien eu lieu
plusieurs chutes dont celle de frank
schleck l'un des favoris du tour
la clavicule cassée le champion du
luxembourg abandonne jours de galère
pour le maillot jaune sylvain chavanel
greffe de foie
satané pavé le français en jette son
vélo dans le fossé
ce soir chavanel n'est plus en tête de
ce tour ennuis mécaniques plus de
crevaisons par dessus ça m'a pas
avantagé ça c'est sûr elle lance
armstrong dans la tourmente
également victime d'une crevaison
l'américain se bat seul et perd à
l'arrivée 55 secondes sur contador
l'espagnol incapable de suivre le rythme
des meilleurs dans les derniers
kilomètres et aremberg c'est le
norvégien hushovd qui s'imposent
mais la bonne affaire est pour andy
schleck le luxembourgeois reprend de
précieuses secondes sur ses rivaux
bien sûr c'est pas mal oh moi mais c'est
un j'ai perdu mon frère aujourd'hui et
une journée seulement après l'avoir cédé
le suisse cancellara récupère son
maillot jaune
cette étape aura tenu toutes ses
promesses
[Musique]